Listen, no matter how I wear this Halara jumpsuit,
I always look and feel amazing.
I showed up to my kids soccer practice after school. Just. Hi.
It's called the breeze full for a reason.
It's loose and flowy,
giving you room to breathe,
but it hugs you up here.
So no matter your size or shape,
you're gonna look amazing.
I'm 5 9 and like, 165 pounds.
I could wear a large.
I size down to a medium because halara,
it just fits beautifully.
This. There is a big discount for first time buyers of the TikTok shop.
They always have big specials going on.
There's free shipping and free returns.
So it's worth it to give it a shot because this thing feels amazing.
The link is right here.